um thanks for attending my talk it's
sometimes thankful to have you talk
after the lunch break sometimes not
i hope you guys are not going to fall
asleep um
and this is going to be generally said
a story about how paypal slowly
transforms into this
new and better company that's started to
adopt a technology stacks like
nodes and lots of other cool things like
go and
i hope that you guys are getting
something out of it i try to leave some
time for q a so let's see and
most good stories usually start with a
little bit of background right that's
like one of those movies where
you go back in time and if you go back
in time it shows
where all the characters come from and
why the
current situation actually exists so
paypal got founded in 1998
as a company called coffinity and back
then in silicon valley everybody had one
of those pda pages
anyone ever owned a palm
okay so those things used to communicate
via infrared
and a few guys including peter thiel
who's nowadays
this enormous investor thought it would
be enormously
awesome if you could send money around
using
infrared and well it didn't really work
out so they started a new product and
another new product and in 1999
one year after they founded the company
they came up with a product called
paypal
because they realized sending around
money in the web is not really easy
so 2000 a company called x.com
ran by elon musk the awesome guy who
runs tesla nowadays
acquired them and then in 2002 they got
acquired by
ebay so a lot of different history and
as long as they exist basically
being one of those kind of oldish
companies in silicon valley nowadays
they had a bunch of different engineers
coming and going
starting stuff nearly finishing it
sometimes they did sometimes not so you
can imagine the technology stack is kind
of a mess
and sometimes if i think about these
scenes
i imagine this all graying out saturn
bone so if you think about jake
archibald with his sounds i should have
totally done that
and the traditional application stacks
that
paypal had were basically two and that's
what we had to fill up a few years
so the first deck was a traditional c
plus plus tech because obviously a lot
of stuff that we do is very processing
heavy
and then there is java which used to do
a lot of the
web apps hosting based on java
with spring jee traditional and it was
kind of effective for a while and our
teams
basically knew how to scale those
applications
but you cannot scale any application to
infinity
and obviously nowadays nobody really
likes to touch these things anymore and
if i look into this room and usually i
give this talk in front of a javascript
audience
everybody looks kind of like that people
are disgusted
c java well obviously not
what we all want to go for i have to be
honest i
used to be a java engineer so please
bear with me
now this is paypal in 2002
and we used to have this big problem
where we had deployments every six weeks
and now if you imagine issues like
there's
this number saying we have a hundred
million users
and this number changes we have to wait
six weeks until we can deploy these
things
and you can imagine how painful that is
and it was not just the website that got
deployed every six weeks
it was also applying to our api so if
something went wrong in our api you had
to wait six weeks until you could
actually fix it
and obviously going forward into our
modern
kind of engineering culture where we do
continuous deployment
and continuous integration and so on
this was really really awkward for our
engineers because we had those engineers
working on different stacks
and they realized that it is incredibly
painful to work on our product
because on the one hand we used to have
our production stack as i said six weeks
of deployment cycles and so on
and then on the other hand we do have
the prototyping stack and that's where
our
developers usually went along and had
modern scripting languages
lots of stuff happening in javascript
sometimes ruby
and those guys were able to basically
come up with new functionality
incredibly fast
and they used modern kind of toolkits
like bootstrap and bauer and so on
and then they had to roll it out into
our regular stack they had to
do a port so instead of just taking the
javascript templates that you just wrote
and all the css
awesomeness they had to come up with
ways to bring that
to our stack and i'm going into this
deck in a second
so we had user testing we had a b tests
we knew what people liked
and then we had to wait six weeks again
at least to roll these features out
and we don't really interact with full
stack engineers on the production stack
so you had the traditional java back-end
guy
and the traditional html kind of web
developer
and those guys didn't really talk to
each other so a lot of those reasons
basically leads to huge problems
obviously
so the situation we were in at that
moment was
actually kind of frustrating we had bc
plus plus stack with
stylesheets for xml we had java
back-end with jsp as i said mostly was
based on spring
and then we had this cool prototyping
stack that i
usually just defined as nodes with
different javascript templates
and we tried out a lot of those
different templating languages
and at one moment actually the big
decision came that we should go for dust
which is heavily driven by linkedin
and people at paypal just started to
adopt it and kind of liked it
i'm going into a few reasons for dust in
a few minutes
but to be honest it's not really about
the templating language
as it's uh in general it's more about
javascript templating
so we had this big issue with our java
stack right
where i'm saying we were running jsp
but before we had jsp we were even
writing our html
css and javascript in java so
it wasn't even jsp pages that were
rendered but
also now a big problem with jsp
is that you usually end up with a lot of
different programming languages
and scripting languages and markup
languages in one file
because you can have html in a jsp file
css
javascript and java so obviously
it was a big mess and we had to get rid
of that
so a few people came up with a ui
toolkit at paypal
that they called spartan and spartan was
a probatary solution based on spring
nowadays we would do that whole thing
different
now big issue with probatary software is
usually that you have a bigger ramp up
time if you bring in new engineers
because those engineers have to learn
about the frameworks have to apply those
frameworks
we had those really bad deployment
cycles
so people were not happy now
there was gladly a big big push into
open source
a lot of great new engineers came into
our companies they used to work for
startups before or other bigger
companies
and they said that open source might be
actually something valuable to pursue
so three reasons why you might want to
go for open source in a company
as i said less ramp up time for your
engineers
they can usually work with the tools
that they know anyway so
they are more efficient in just doing
work on the two sets that they know
already
then there's this big issue where
engineers often have to focus on setting
up environments and
setting up the project and all that
stuff instead of actually building the
app
you want that your engineers can build
what you want to achieve and not have to
do all these setup work because that's
less efficient obviously and you waste a
lot of time
and then obviously the last reason is
proprietary solutions are seldom better
than the
open source ones there are great open
source projects out there with thousands
and hundred thousands of committers
so why don't you just go for that and
try to
bring some benefit into this
so we came up with rapid deployment and
development cycles and everything was
great right
on our production stack we still had to
go with the old stuff
so we ended up with a push into
going into a new production stack and
this all was still before we introduced
node.js so we had bootstrap in the front
end
we had javascript templating as i said
and
then if you want to go for our regular
stacks
i said that we have c plus and java so
what we did is we
injected the c plus v8 engine into our c
plus deck that was fairly easy we call
that the project delorean
so if you remember delorean from the
back to the future
it's that awesome car that does the time
jumping stuff so we thought it was kind
of
a fit and then there is mozilla's rhino
which is a full javascript
implementation in java
so that's what we used on our java stack
to run the different templates
and looking at that basically we had now
a few different kind of environments
again prototyping
we went with dust and it was great now
since we settled on using
dust also on our java stack we leveraged
rhino
and we were able to run the same
templates that we wrote for our
prototyping stack
on production as well and that was
obviously great for us because it helped
us to
not leave the old stacks behind because
if you want to push for
new apps it's obviously an easy choice
to say we want to go for nodes and we
want to go for
awesome javascript templates and we
leave the old stuff behind but since we
have so many different applications
that was not really something that we
could do
so we wanted to try out notes in
production
and this one thought this one wish
came from a simple project paypal
checkout page that you might know if you
go
and buy something online and it
redirects you to paypal
generates more than 3.5 billion dollars
every year
and we thought why not start at
the core of paypal at the one thing that
drives most of our revenue
so a project got named after we got
hermes
gots born and hermes is the god of
agility and mobility
so what we did is we started with a very
simple stack that we just introduced
at the beginning of that week so we had
node.js running we used bootstrap to do
some
very lean ui and we used some other open
source as i mentioned we used
bower and the first prototype of the new
checkout platform was born in three days
and people were incredibly excited
because we didn't have to
fiddle around with our old frameworks it
was much easier for
new engineers to get involved so that
was great
and then we thought we should definitely
try this with another project
and that's the account page the paypal
wallet app
so if you go to paypal and log in over
there and you see your balance and your
funding sources and all that stuff
that is actually the first project that
we did
and it's actually kind of risk to go for
a new platform in production if you're
not sure that it's really running
so what we did is we had first this
initial project if we checkout page and
people were convinced we should try it
right
so we had two teams starting with two
projects the first team was a
traditional java team that was used to
our stack
and was well trained in actually
building apps on this deck
the second team was only two javascript
engineers compared to five java
engineers
and they were supposed to just give it a
try and build the same kind of
experience
so we started in january in 2013
and the java team obviously used the
existing components and started building
the app
in march just two months after the
environment for node was completely set
up so we had
key stores we had logging services we uh
we knew how to connect to our databases
and so on so that's what we two
engineers built on javascript
now in june the two teams met crossroads
so in terms of functionality both
applications were on power
one team five java engineers started
with all the existing services
the other team was just two node
engineers
so we ran a few functionality tests and
all of them passed and we were actually
really convinced that this is a good
sign
and run a few benchmarks so
i don't want to bore you too much with
numbers but just to quickly go into it
we have a bunch of different requests
with number of users
and this is the javastack and you see
the java stack actually averages
at some point at about 11 pages per
seconds
starting with one user per request
and then we go higher up to 15 users
that request at the same time
now this is five cores for actually
production hardware that we are using
and then we had the note stack and the
node stack
actually serves nearly wv requests and
the same stuff happens just on one core
at that moment
so it was a very young new stack
it was barely optimized and was more
efficient straight away
obviously you cannot really compare
apples to peaches
so it's not completely fair to compare
those two
because one is using our proprietary
java kind of stack
the other not but at least for us it was
a good sign that we could go ahead with
this
a few more numbers that we had were
pretty much the codes was actually very
lean we had to write less codes to
achieve the same
and we needed less engineers to do the
same work
so we were kind of convinced to go ahead
now our java engineers gladly were not
so negative about it started to
contribute to parallel work streams
and got taught to get some more
note skills and javascript skills
now the new stack at paypal changed over
and
what we have right now is c plus plus we
have
java serving some older apps and all the
new new apps
running nodes and i think the biggest
step into this direction for us was
actually decoupling our ui first
because obviously if your application
layer and the ui layer are
really tightly integrated it's very very
hard for you to
iterate and go ahead and start a new
stack
so now that we are able to run dust on
all those three different stacks
we can basically bring all new features
to all stacks which is amazing
for us now since we do javascript
templating
it comes with a big benefit that we can
run the render both
on the client side and the server side
and
we actually use that quite a lot so what
you will see if you go to paypal.com
the initial start page is always
rendered on server side and then for
dynamic content
we can decide on the fly if we want to
render that ahead or just when the
client really loads it up
so um one of the benefits of node is
obviously the node package manager
and we use it heavily to actually
distribute
our internal services so if we want to
use our monitoring services security
anything that actually interacts with
our c
plus tech we can just go ahead and
install some npm modules
and we're using an internal npm proxy
for that
which i will show in a few seconds as
well
we had this situation we were finally
able to uh
start and actually go ahead and use
nodes and we had
dust and everything was great right so
for us
this was the moment to release with
kraken
and the animation you just saw
took me about half an hour
so please bear with me so
with kraken we actually had this one
situation
where a lot of different teams have been
working on nodes they leveraged
express we used harpy lots of different
kind of
ways to build our servers and a few best
practices actually
started together so kraken is a
suit on top of express um it's not a
whole framework i wouldn't call it
framework
and it comes with a lot of kind of
sensible defaults a lot of
pre-configured stuff that makes sense
so as i said we used dust for templating
but it doesn't necessarily have to be
dust so if you like jade or if you like
ejs or anything else
you can just go ahead and use that and
originally it was made to make
middle scaled to corporate scales
companies
adopt node faster but we actually
noticed that lots of startups
started using nest and started using
kraken
because they didn't have to care about
security and a lot of other stuff
and it heavily taps into middleware
which obviously comes both
with express and cracking at moments
now the reason is as i said lots of
different teams at paper
are working on the same kind of stacks
and they build different apps
now if you have a lot of teams building
apps in the same frameworks or different
frameworks you will realize
everybody configures frameworks
differently
if you have now engineers moving from
one project into another
they're kind of lost because
configuration is made different
some of them might use some json files
for configuration
some of them use some methods to
initialize things so it was a big mess
and we tried to resolve that by bringing
some
best practices into that and now i
already said it before they have
actually more time to build projects
instead of just setting up the
environments which is really good for us
the project structure is actually kind
of opinionated
so we try to push for a clear model view
controller
way and we used that initially by having
um kind of different frameworks so we
used backbone and a lot of other
frameworks
but it was a bit too heavy for us so we
just went ahead and
did our own folder structure and that
works incredibly well for us
so we have those templates as i said can
be rendered both server and
client sides it comes with unit testing
straight ahead
and what is interesting about kraken is
that we moved the
logic away from our initial index.js or
app.js file
into the different controllers so
controllers handle routing
and a lot of other stuff and this is
something that you can actually see
is now also present in express four so
express three initially didn't have that
and they actually moved it over into
express four as well because they
realized it helps to
have much cleaner files and way more
structure
and i think the best for
modules and there is a whole lot of
different modules that come with it
amakara luska adaro and kappa
makara is used to do
internationalization localization or
specialization in your apps
lusca is coming with a lot of sensible
security defaults
adaro is used to bring dust.js support
and kappa is our npm proxy
now if you want to do a localization
it's actually quite easy we use key
value files for that
it's not json it's our own kind of
format with property files and you just
load
up lots of different content bundles and
you can do that
on the fly or you can obviously use
kraken to do that for you
but you don't have to use kraken to use
all of these modules
so what we do is we have a provider that
just loads for various locates
and it basically provides those
different values for you which is kind
of good
and the property files are not really
complex as i said it's not json syntax
but it allows for some structures where
you can bring arrays in there
you can define multiple values it's
actually kind of useful for us
you don't have to use this format but i
think it's actually pretty good since it
also supports some more structure like
sub keys
now if you want to use this it actually
heavily taps into
dust so one of the good things about it
is if you switch the local it
automatically
changes changes we locate for you in the
templates as well
by leveraging before folder structure so
different keys in different languages
get resolved for you
which is very handy and you can see that
down below with the header tag so it
basically just loads up the
index.creating
and index is my controller so
my localization is bound to my
controller and it just basically loads
in the file for me which is
really handy for us
and if i want to use adaro i basically
just defined dust as my view engine for
express
obviously i can still as i said before
use any other view engine
it's just dust for us because
a lot of view engines try to have a lot
of logic in their files and they
try to do a lot of processing for you
and calculations and that stuff and we
tend to move that
rather into our controller logic so
you basically have a layout and you
provide your powershells into it
and what happens is it fills up the
content so nothing new nothing magic in
there
dust comes with some cool stuff like
sections and you can provide your view
context into that
so different models can be just rendered
directly
and it also comes with conditioners
so not too much logic because it's just
saying
if a certain content is there show it or
don't show it
so it doesn't really try to be that
smart
now security is something that i think
is kind of interesting
lots of frameworks come with security
measurements and lots of kind of ways to
make your app secure and harden it but
lots of those frameworks also don't come
with sensible defaults so they just
assume you do the configuration
and quite often developers tend to not
do that
so one of the biggest features we
support is
prevention of cross cross site request
forgery for cserv
and it basically says if you want to
manipulate my data with
post requests put or delete you have to
provide a token
to make sure that it's really the app
and not somebody else click checking
which basically means
i'm framing your website in another
website
can be prevented by setting up the same
origin header
it comes with output escaping against
cross-site scripting and content
security policy support
and if you've attended last year's js
conf you might have seen mike west
talking about content security policy
it's really awesome stuff configuration
happens via
json so you basically just say i want
that feature i don't want to have that
feature
this is my setting or you can just go
through the method calls one by one so
you don't have to use all those kind of
things
now i already mentioned you have to
provide a token
and it's basically just a hidden input
field that you provide
over to the app and then it basically
validates it's usually your app
manipulating the data
the npm proxy kappa is very easy to
install you can go for that globally or
locally and that's basically what we use
to distribute our different services
like the keystore database access
logging monitoring and it's based on
another module called
npm delegate and if you look at the
configuration it's really just a folder
called config and in that folder you
have a bunch of different files
and you can set up various environments
so you can say this is my staging config
this is my development
this is my test environment and it's
pretty much
easy to set up in this case you see
the view engines and you can obviously
do that for all the kind of different
settings for kraken
now if you want to set up kraken with
let's say passport
you could go and really just configure
it by providing some options to it
and this is just the index.js file that
you would use for that
and now the nice thing is about that
you don't need to mess around with your
life cycle you don't need to
figure out when is my module being
loaded and why
you just tap into different events like
in this case middleware
so after my session is loaded i make
sure that my i can use my passport local
strategy
i just make sure that the user is nicely
serialized and deserialized and that's
it
so it provides a very very clean way to
make sure that my projects are nicely
and visible
so i think it helps a lot and
since we wanted to make sure that people
don't have to set up this stuff
manually and it comes with a yeoman
generator
so you do npm install generator kraken
call your cracking in your shell and
that's it
it's really easy to set up and i think
it is pretty cool because it
does a lot of scaffolding for you so it
comes with your templates it comes with
your localization with the tests
automatically
which is really useful for all of us i
guess
so kraken nowadays is already in version
1.x
which also came with the express four
push
and i think one of the features that we
will
focus on heavily is going to be
specialization which is not going to be
purely used for a b testing but also for
mobile device versus desktop and so on
so it allows us to do a lot of this kind
of logic
and well i can summarize for us it has
been actually
a really good right to introduce node
and especially kraken to the company
we have those really small teams with
lots of javascript full stack engineers
that are able to move much faster we can
write
our applications more efficiently we
have now dust as one
ui layer so we don't have to mess around
with different templates
and it was our very first big push into
open source
so for us it really helped to make sure
that we are not just building profit so
appropriate
sorry proprietary software for paypal
and release that to be wired
we actually tried to figure out what
would be useful for everybody
and our teams are now so convinced that
all the new apps are going to be
written on note purely big thanks for
attending my talk
and i'm open for some questions
you